bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu
le journal de la rédaction 26 minutes
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
l'essentiel voici les titres en images
des années 30 millions d'euros investis
dans cet établissement de saint cyr
l'école elle le lycée jean perrin à
dévoiler son nouveau visage ce matin
lors de son inauguration il offre aussi
de nouvelles formations les université
de versailles saint quentin est de cergy
ouvriront un institut d'études
politiques à serge armand 2014 première
création d'un établissement de ce type
depuis 20 ans il sera aussi le premier
en ile de france
nous en parlerons en détail en plateau
avec son directeur adjoint installé à
houdan enfin jean-luc legrand est il le
meilleur boulanger de france il est en
tout cas en finale régionale de cette
émission de télé et diffusée sur m6 et
nous l'avons rencontré à l'image du jour
l'image de ce 11 septembre 2013 la voix
si elle est signée jonathan willeman
l'inauguration des étangs gaubert à
versailles dans le cadre de l'année le
nôtre célébrant le 400e anniversaire de
la naissance du paysagiste de louis xiv
elle les anciens réservoirs laissé à
l'abandon des fontaines du château sont
devenus jardin michel desvigne
paysagiste et inès en chine et s'arrache
architectes ont travaillé ensemble pour
réaliser ce poumon vert à proximité de
la gare des chantiers le public pourra
le découvrir lors des journées du
patrimoine ce week end ses jardins
seront ensuite ouverts tous les jours de
8 ans de travaux le lycée jean perrin
saint cyr l'école a connu plus qu'un
léger lifting la fin des travaux a été
inauguré ce mercredi matin en présence
notamment du président de la région jean
paul huchon le point sur les changements
et sur la nouvelle offre de formations
proposées avec violaine thorez elodie
moines pour les images jean paul huchon
tenait à être présent et pour cause cela
fait huit ans que le lycée jean perrin
était en travaux le président ps de la
région ile de france ne voulait pas
manquer l'inauguration
le conseil régional a investi 34
millions d'euros pour la réfection du
bâtiment
un bâtiment qui date des années 60 et
qui souffrait de problèmes de sécurité
et des espaces le temps des travaux
les élèves étaient accueillis dans des
préfabriqués pas toujours en bon état il
des problème aujourd'hui résolu
on a eu des soucis en informatique était
là savarese les locaux aussi nouveau
température s'était pas trop ça
maintenant on est mieux
donc c'est un site vraiment à me
travailler c'est ses proies et ça donne
envie de travailler ça donne envie de
rentrer de venir tous les matins
d'hallencourt et tours deux bâtiments
ont été gardés et rénové celui du milieu
a été reconstruit pour assurer une
meilleure liaison résultats des locaux
beaucoup plus fonctionnel et un accès
pour les handicapés facilité de quoi
donner de belles perspectives à la
proviseure du lycée
j'espère bien remonter les effectifs et
changer l'image aussi de l'établissement
sur la commune l'intercommunalité voir
le département puisque nous avons des
filières exclusive dans le département
marchandisage visuel n'existe que au
lycée jean-perrin de même que l'optique
c'est le seul lycée public du
département à offrir une filière optique
ici le magasin pédagogique véritable
réplique d'un commerce ou les élèves
conseils de vrais clients
ils viennent avec leurs facs de maladie
et bénéficient de tarifs préférentiels
sur les lunettes
l'établissement ne compte pas s'arrêter
là l'ouverture d'un bts dans le domaine
est actuellement à l'étude
toujours à saint cyr l'école la
bibliothèque albert camus va connaître
elle aussi du changement cette année
ouverte dans les années 70 ces locaux de
220 mètres carrés ne possède pas
d'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite c'est donc un
déménagement qui sera opéré mi novembre
à la bibliothèque occupera le rez de
chaussée d'un immeuble rue lucien
sampaix qui est hébergé par le passé
caserne de pompiers puis stations
service changement de décor donc budget
240000 euros l'ancienne bibliothèque
devrait accueillir un relais assistantes
maternelles
on va offrir de nouveaux services il y
aura d'abord plus de place et il y aura
des postes informatiques alors qu'avant
on en avait un
là je crois que mon nom à 5 on va
pouvoir avoir un plus grand espace pour
les enfants il n'y aura pas beaucoup
plus de livre qu'avant mais elle
répondra aux normes et
il ya beaucoup plus de place et les gens
n'auront pas cette impression d'être en
sous sol après la rénovation d'un lycée
d'une bibliothèque on reste dans le
domaine de l'éducation avec l'invité de
cette édition avis et critiques bonsoir
vous êtes professeur de sciences
politiques à l'université de versailles
saint quentin directeur adjoint de
l'institut d'études politiques grand
paris ouest qui va ouvrir officiellement
pour les élèves à la rentrée 2014 nous
avions déjà évoqué sur cette antenne la
création de cet ep le premier depuis
vingt ans à travers la france le premier
dans la région ile de france également
on avait évoqué une ouverture plutôt
septembre 2013 dès cette année un an de
retard
comment ça s'explique non il n'y a pas
vraiment un an de retard je pense qu'il
y ait eu quelques erreurs de
communication sur l'ouverture en 2013
mais c'était une ouverture qui était
absolument pas faisable pour pour tout
un tas de raisons logistiques donc on
ouvrira bien en septembre 2014 avec une
première année une première promotion de
80 étudiants qui sera une première année
un petit peu préparatoire donc moins
importante qu'elle ne sera par la suite
puisqu'on devrait monter à 100 voire 120
étudiants en tout cas en 2014 on ouvre
pour 80 places et ce sera donc dans les
locaux de saint germain en l'air on le
voit ta l'image ce sont les locaux de
l'ancienne unité artitude formation des
maîtres lui depuis a disparu et ses
locaux elles seront donc servir à
accueillir ali ep à
saint-germain-en-laye un an de retard
vous nous dites c'est pas vraiment du
retard
en tout cas vous n'avez pas non plus
changé elle le mode de fonctionnement de
lieux paix qui était annoncé il était
question à l'époque de mettre l'accent
par exemple sur les sciences sociales
les langues aussi avec un partenariat
avec le lycée international voisins
alors tout ça est en voie de
construction mais en effet le lieu paix
sera un ep totalement standard qui
respectera la charte des irp et de
région avec lesquels nous associons des
six grands diop et de région c'est à
dire avec un enseignement très
généraliste dans les deux premières
années une troisième année à l'étranger
et ensuite deux dernières années qui
sont des années nettement plus
professionnalisantes avec peut-être une
petite particularité chez nous c'est que
la dernière année
dennis hope et se fera dans un certain
nombre de masters déjà présents parmi
les deux unis dans le cadre des deux
universités partenaires l'université
versailles saint quentin et l'université
de cergy pontoise philippe ce qui
permettra aux étudiants une double
diplômation une diplomation et ep et une
double diplômation master 2 comment vous
êtes mis d'accord justement avec l'autre
universités celle de cergy-pontoise
université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour vous à répartir un
petit peu les rôles et quels seront les
passerelles aussi avec lieu p alors
comment on s'est mis d'accord on s'est
mis d'accord d'abord parce qu'on est un
ensemble de collègues qui sont en dons
très bien et qui appartenons pour
beaucoup à des disciplines qui sont des
disciplines sauf que ce soit le droit la
science politique l'histoire la
sociologie ainsi que l'économie donc il
ya eu un assez fort consensus entre ses
différentes disciplines pour fonder
comme ça un institut d'excellence mais
un institut d'excellence qui ne soient
pas coupés des universités parce que
nous on fait partie des universitaires
qui regrette ont très fortement cette
coupure ce qui va d'ailleurs dans le
sens de la volonté gouvernementale entre
les grandes écoles et les universités
université font de la recherche et
universités ont des enseignants qui sont
de très grande qualité
donc ya pas vraiment de raison qu'ils
essaient de coupure donc on s'est mis
d'accord pour fonder comme ça un
institut qui certes soit sélectif qui va
amener des étudiants qui sont des
étudiants de très bon niveau mais qui va
les faire qui va les faire participer à
la vie de l'université particulièrement
en des ans dernières années et qui
seront eux mêmes alimentés par des
universitaires par une grande majorité
des universitaires des deux composantes
c'est ce qui vous démarque des autres
instituts d'études politiques
on va totalement puisque par exemple
l'institut d'études politiques de
strasbourg qui fait partie du réseau des
6 iep et de région lui aussi rattachés à
une université les autres sont plutôt
des établissements publics autonomes et
même dans les autres 6e p il ya quand
même des universitaires qui enseigne non
nous ce qui va nous démarquer assez
fortement je dirais c'est trois choses
c'est cette idée de cette cinquième
année qui se fera au sein des masters
c'est le fait qu'en effet on va essayer
de mettre en place un partenariat très
important avec le lycée international de
saint germain en laye ce qui nous
permettra de proposer à nos étudiants
attrait
grand nombre de langues étrangères ce
qui est toujours une très bonne chose
dans les zup et en tout cas beaucoup
plus que ce que les yeux paix propose
classiquement même ce que lio p paris
est capable de proposer
donc ça c'est véritablement des choses
qui vont débarquer depuis la troisième
chose c'est que lio paix sera constituée
autour de quatre sections deux sections
à ses standards sur l'europe et
l'international et l'autre sur
l'économie et des finances mais deux
sections plus particulière sur le
patrimoine et la communication et la
gouvernance territoriale locale qui sont
des points forts de nos deux universités
il faut se démarquer par rapport aux
autres instituts d'études politiques est
ce qu'il y à une concurrence entre les
instituts d'études politiques
je sais pas s'il ya une vraie
concurrence là aujourd'hui il ya une
concurrence qui existe entre les
universités de freige universal c'est
vrai mais entre les yeux baissés
peut-être moins vrai d'ailleurs on a été
très très bien accueilli par les
sixièmes et de région pierre mathiot qui
dirige les ep 2 il a été un véritable
parrain morale pour nous donc là-dessus
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de problème
vous savez je dirais le gâteau il est
assez large pour qu'on se le partagent
vous avez à peu près neuf mille neuf
mille cinq cents étudiants qui passent
au concours en première année pour 1000
places à peine ce qui fait un taux de
sélectivité important mais un taux de
sélectivité qui ne va pas vraiment
changé avec l'arrivée d'une première
promotion de 80 places de la donner
quelques chiffres aussi puisque vous
avez cité 80 places à terme ses 800
étudiants que vous allez accueillir
d'ici d'ici cinq ans environ sur ce site
à saint germain 1 1 million d'euros pour
la première année pour le budget de 3
millions 8 en vitesse de croisière
c'est ambitieux c'est pas vraiment
ambitieux c'est juste nécessaire c'est
même un minimum nécessaire avec quelques
interrogations je ne cache pas
interrogation qui viennent du fait que
pour l'instant l'état ne prévoit pas de
verser de subventions ce qui ferait de
nous le seul lieu paix qui ne seraient
pas financées par les tables vous
essayez négocié un peu pourquoi ça
serait une réponse officielle au moins
non j'ai une réponse très officieuse et
et que chacun peut comprendre l'état des
finances publiques étant ce qu'il est je
pense que l'état préféré que ce soient
les collectivités locales et les deux
universités partenaires
qu'ils mettent de l'argent ce qu'ils
feront à la fois les collectivités
locales et les universités partenaires
mais c'est un lieu que je dirais qu'il
sera pas extrêmement coûteux dans la
mesure où une grosse partie une immense
partie de la masse salariale enseignante
viendra des deux universités partenaires
au projet rémunérer les enseignants qui
ont des heures supplémentaires ça c'est
sûr qu'on clip agissent bien l'objectif
c'est aussi d'obtenir une mixité sociale
20 % de boursiers accueilli rentrée 2014
quelques places leur sont déjà réservés
non il n'ya pas des places qui sont
réservées on ne fonctionnera pas par
quotas on fonctionnera avec un système
d' aide aux concours
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir il ya
d'ores et déjà un partenariat avec cet
établissement secondaire pour aider les
étudiants les lycéens
disons qu'ils viennent de zones en
difficulté à mieux se préparer aux
concours de première année de la même
façon qu'on va mettre en place à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et particulièrement en faculté de droit
et sciences politiques
un parcours de préparation aux concours
pour la quatrième année puisqu'il ya une
capacité une possibilité d'intégrer ni
op après une licence en 4e année des
élèves des étudiants qu'ils soient
boursiers voulons se sont déjà
manifestés pour intégrer les ep oui ça
je vous cache pas que il ya c'est un
projet qui connaît un qui connaît un
vrai succès je me fais guère de soucis
sur nos capacité d'attraction
ensuite ça va se dérouler comme en date
des concours pour ceux qui veulent
véritablement s'inscrire alors pas de
rentrer et en 2000 camions pour cette
première année le concours commun il va
être très rapidement mise en place
puisqu'il est mise en place à partir de
la fin octobre
il se déroule je crois le 24 mai pour
être très précis qui va être un samedi
d'ailleurs samedi 24 mai
ou d'ailleurs normalement ici à saint
quentin en yvelines et à cergy on
accueillera quelques 2000 étudiants pour
kate et demi de candidats au concours et
les inscriptions se font il suffit
d'aller sur le site internet des irp et
du réseau des iut de régions où il ya
toute la procédure d'inscription qui est
en place une des raisons qui a motivé la
création de cette équipe et je crois
qu'il faut vraiment avoir ces chiffres
en tête c'est que sur les 9000 étudiants
qui passent le concours 40 % viennent
d'île de france
or ça sera le soleil op de région je
mets lieu ppary à part parce qu'il est à
part en effet c'est le seul lieu p2
région qui sera située en ile de france
hier que les étudiants aller très loin
pour suivre leurs études au sein d'un
très loin comme aix ou toulouse - loin
comme rennes ou lille 1 rennes lille
strasbourg lyon ex toulouse sont les més
eazy e p2 ceux de ce réseau on vient
avec eux désormais nous ce concept mais
au moins il y aura une offre en
ile-de-france pour une masse d'étudiants
qui nous tout de même très importante
pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi d'études
au sein d'un institut d'études
politiques
on y apprend quoi et quels débouchés
surtout alors on n'y apprend pas
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
à devenir un homme politique je suis pas
persuadé que ça prenne dans des
instituts on y apprend beaucoup de
choses et les débouchés sont extrêmement
nombreux c'est ce qui fait la richesse
de cette formation on y apprend d'abord
avoir une très solide culture
généralistes dans les deux premières
années
ensuite il ya des voies de
professionnalisation qui débouche sur
les métiers de la finance de l'économie
sur les métiers de l'international sur
les concours bien entendu concours
locaux ou encore la fonction publique
nationale et puis tout un tas de métiers
autour de la communication du
journalisme qui sont des métiers qui
embauchent
beaucoup de gens qui sont développés et
peut-être un futur président de la
république passera par à l'iut de saint
quentin en yvelines on l'espère de la
région ile de france
merci à vous qui l'aviez crétier
professeur de sciences politiques à lui
est ce qu directeur adjoint de
l'institut d'études politiques grand
paris ouest qui va donc ouvrir en
septembre 2014 ce sera le premier ep de
la région ile-de-france et puis le
premier créé depuis une vingtaine
d'années est sans doute l'un des
derniers peut être probablement l'un des
biens dits oui je je pense merci à vous
on passa à l'économie à présent les
clubs d'affaires qui permettent aux
chefs d'entreprises de se retrouver se
multiplient certains se différencient
parfois c'est le cas de l'happy hour
business à 50 cents en yvelines tournée
vers la culture première réunion et hier
soir catherine plateau patrick jacques
de dixmude un nouveau club d'affaires à
saint quentin en yvelines le happy hour
reportage que vous redécouvrirez d'ici
la fin de cette édition lors de cette
happy hour business à saint quentin en
yvelines ce club qui donnait sa première
rencontre hier etienne krieger
professeur affilié à hec était présent
c'était le premier intervenant et nous
lui avons justement demandé de préciser
sa pensée positive vous en avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler et nous
développe plus particulièrement
l'importance de la confiance
écoutez la confiance est un peu lié à
votre histoire personnelle si vous avez
été gravement trahi dans vos jeunes
années vous serez un peu plus méfiant
mais fondamentalement la confiance est
un pari sur la compétence et sur le
les intentions de quelqu'un est donc
finalement ce qui s'apprend c'est faire
preuve de discernement
généralement avec l'expérience vous
faites ou cette preuve de plus de
discernement et vous fait confiance à
bon escient
mais il ya toujours une dimension de
risque qui fait que voilà il ya une
prise de risque et que vous ne gagnez
pas à tous les coups sinon c'est du
calcul et la confiance n'a plus besoin
d'être donc baski safran c'est faire
preuve de plus de discernement ne pas
prendre de risques fous mais
fondamentalement
il ya toujours des impondérables c'est
ce qui fait le plaisir de la chose sinon
on serait dans un monde totalement
calculatoire dans des relations
économiques ou vous avez un
environnement quand même relativement
cadrés ou vous avez un droit des
affaires je pense que voilà vous ne vous
ne risquez pas tout et c'est un pari en
fait c'est comme ça se rapproche du pari
pascalien finalement si vous faites
confiance et que vous faites de plus en
plus de discernement vous allez aussi
suscité une spirale de confiance et pas
de l'angélisme c'est simplement une
question de pratique si à un moment
donné vous cadenas c'est tout un moment
donné plus personne ne s'adressera avoué
est donc un moment donné vous serez pas
gagnante où vous serez assis sur un sur
un tas d'or sans en profiter
chaque fois qu'on essaie d'évacuer la
confiance par des mécanismes de contrôle
ou d'intéressement on déshumanise les
gens ont leurs angoisses finalement une
notion de machines de mercenaires et
donc du coup les gens ne donnent pas le
meilleur d'eux mêmes et on arrive dans
la spirale
la spirale négative dont je parle est
donc finalement la confiance est
absolument nécessaire et il a des vertus
auto-réalisatrice évidemment pas avec
quelqu'un de malhonnête mais si je vous
fais confiance vous vous sentirez
investi de ma confiance et vous allez
donner le meilleur de vous mêmes c'est
le charme de cette notion etienne
krieger donc professeur à hec qui était
le premier intervenant de ce club a payé
business hour qui a été lancé à saint
quentin en yvelines le reportage complet
sur le lancement cette première
rencontre qui se déroulait à saint
quentin en yvelines le reportage est à
retrouver sur notre site internet dès à
présent ce week end se dérouleront les
journées du patrimoine samedi le service
archéologique et des yvelines propose de
découvrir le parcours des objets qui
sont découverts lors des fouilles
visite en avant première dans ce journal
avec aurélia de bissy et jonathan vilma
à l'occasion des journées européennes du
patrimoine initiée aux amateurs pourront
découvrir à montigny-le-bretonneux
samedi 14 septembre la face cachée de
l'archéologie au cours d'une visite
commentée des professionnels du service
archéologique des yvelines propose au
public de suivre le parcours d'études
des objets les objets n'arrive pas tout
nettoyé dans la terre et qu'il ya tout
un travail sur les objets qui est un
travail de conservation pour essayer de
l'accroître leur durée de vie on va dire
et aussi tout un travail de restauration
pour leur permettre pour permettre aux
archéologues de les étudier et aux
visiteurs de les apprécier lors
d'expositions les archéologues pour
comprendre les objets n'ont pas
seulement besoin delà même des mêmes
types de traitement que l'on va faire
pour présenter au grand public notamment
pour ce qui est du comblement des
parties manquantes ont les arts que la
cli connaissent bien des objets sont
capables d'imaginer ce qui manque
alors que pour les landes publics ont
fait un effort de comblement parce que
c'est plus facile souvent d'appréhender
un onglet lorsqu'il est quand même
lorsque volumes et les restitue les
visiteurs pourront observer différents
objets et collections issues des
interventions menées sur tout le
département
certaines opérations récentes ont
d'ailleurs mis à jour des découvertes
étonnantes et unique
cette année on a fait de diagnostics et
les deux hommes ont apporté des récifs
tout à fait passionnant alors la
première opération qui a déroulé aux
mureaux a permis de découvrir trois
tombes et dans l'une de ces tombes
il y avait un objet un petit poignard en
bronze tout à fait passionnant parce qu
en fait est un objet unique en france
qui est datée à peu près de moins 1800
moins 1600 moins de 6 ans avant
jésus-christ ce qu'on appelle l'âge du
bronze et kita est très mal connue dans
les aigus donc c'est vraiment ça apporte
une connaissance tout à fait nouvelle et
la deuxième opération dont qu'ils aient
lieu à cher là a permis de découvrir
vraiment quelque chose d'encore plus je
dirais clinique c'est des restes humains
et ils ont été datés ces restes humains
et ils seraient de moins huit mille ans
avant jésus christ est en fait en gros
le plus ancien yvelinois en fait qu'on
aurait puisque on a des objets bien plus
anciens ou en quatre cent mille ans mais
en restes d'individus de personnes ce
serait le plus ancien
quelques deux cent quarante mille objets
inventorié de toutes époques et de tous
types de matériaux sont conservées dans
les réserves du service archéologique
des yvelines et pour tout savoir des
prochaines journées du patrimoine rendez
vous avec le kiosque le magazine
culturel la rédaction de télé fils
présenté par aurélia double ici c'est
aujourd'hui mercredi à 18h30 19h30 à 23h
sur téléphiles et en replay sur notre
site internet
jean luc legrand et boulanger à houdan
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu son nom
à la télé il participé cette semaine à
l'émission la meilleure boulangerie de
france est sur m6 le but relever des
défis en boulangerie et pâtisserie
sa spécialité la brioche au nougat et ça
a séduit le jury il s'est qualifié lundi
pour la finale régionale
il revient sur cette expérience au micro
de claire cambier embouti que j'avais
aucune difficulté en fait la difficulté
ça s'est fait plus tôt
dans l'émission vous allez voir vendredi
en fait parce que donc on s'est retrouvé
en finale et ça s'est passé dans un cfa
donc nous demander quelques épreuves de
coin pâtisserie pâtisserie boulangère
mais qu'on me dise mais voilà moi je mon
truc c'est donc c'était plus simple
autres pâtissier je me suis retrouvé
face à des d'autres entreprises beaucoup
plus plus grande que moi c'était un peu
david contre goliath
moi j'y suis avec mon apprenti on était
deux les autres gt3 avec des gens
beaucoup plus âgés et quelques apprentis
aussi mais c'était des plus grosses
structures pour ceux qui s'expriment
donnait un peu peur mais en fait on sent
très très bien sorti et non non on a
passé un très bon en fait fin du
suspense pour ce boulanger vendredi
17h35 cité près très près si on lui
souhaite bien évidemment bonne chance et
puisque l'on parle boulangerie justement
quels sont vos critères à quoi
reconnaît-on un bon pain c'est notre
question du jour question très sérieuse
posée par nos journalistes du bon pain
fait du bon blé déjà
donc du bon blé c'est du blé sans
pesticides ni matières chimiques etc
c'est du bon le vin aussi donc au levain
forcément et puis après c'est un
boulanger qui aime faire du pain ou
simplement qui fait ça au four donc
voilà c'est
un pas qu'ils respectent peut-être deux
mille ans de tradition de pain qu'ils
soient pas la pâte à papier comme on en
trouve souvent qui est moyen
c'est du pin a pas trop cuit du bon pas
il doit être à la fois croustillant
assez cuit moelleux et il doit pouvoir
résister à une journée en fin de journée
on doit pouvoir le déguster avec autant
de bonheur que le matin en l'ayant
acheté c'est une baguette bien cuite
croustillantes et surtout qui qui
n'augmentent pas à qui n'augmentent pas
effectivement c'est important chacun a
ses critères très précis pour juger un
bon pain de 5 à 500 euros
c'est ce que vous pouvez verser à
l'artiste saint quentinois alex et sa
guitare afin de l'aider dans la
réalisation de son nouvel album trois
titres 3500 euros lui sont nécessaires
et il fait appel au public via une
plateforme internet participative ulule
pour chaque somme versée une
contrepartie places de concerts cd dvd
alex et sa guitare de la chanson
française entre humour et tendresse
c'est ainsi qu'il se définit si vous
n'avez pas encore découvert sur scène
lors de l'un de ses 400 concerts donnés
ces dernières années voici un extrait de
son dernier clip consacré au régime
juste après le pain c'est bien
évidemment
les régimes samo con
ça me bouffe la vie c'est les régimes
ça me comble
ça me bouffe la vie que je me disais je
au nord
la régie
pour sue pour soutenir à l'excès et sa
guitare dans la réalisation de son
prochain album je vous redonne le site
ulule point fr c'est la fin de cette
édition du journal du 11 septembre je
vous retrouve demain jeudi pour
l'essentiel de l'information locale je
recevrai pour l'invité du journal yves
vandewalle
il est président du parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse également
conseiller général des yvelines et ils
se mobilisent face à la loi du flou qui
est actuellement étudié à l'assemblée et
au sénat je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée
on vous retrouve demain